I read some,
a dissertation about how male feminists
think about themselves and how they go
about having sex.
For example,
every one of the men said that he's,
he's way to approach sex was that he
didn't take any initiative because he
would,
he would foul,
uh,
the,
the file,
the whole situation and the woman.
Yeah.
Well,
it's like Andrea to work in a back in
the 70s that horrible.
She's a horrible creature.
Andrea at the work.
And,
uh,
you know,
she said that it's men engaged in sexual
behavior with an erect penis.
That that was,
ah,
that,
that was equivalent to violence.
Right.
That was equivalent to rate.
Yeah.
So,
I mean,
I don't even know what to say about
that,
except that that's exactly what Andrea
to work and was like.
And she was a real heroine to the
radical feminists,
you know,
Harun where someone else around that
period of time,
dude,
Catherine Mckinnon,
I think her name was equally,
equally
well,
I think a red book.
Yeah.
Well,
you would've,
you would've.
Yeah.
I mean,
from my perspective as a clinician,
those people have clear every indication
of serious personality disorders.
And I actually think to some degree that
we've made a haven for people who have
serious personality pathology in these,
in these pseudo disciplines,
in the universities.
And you know,
you said something interesting you said
that,
uh,
you know,
when you went to,
to when you took your sociology degree,
that these were basically fringe views.
Now their center views in the
university,
but also implying that they're
increasingly dominant views in society.
And that's the thing is that people
think that these are somehow ivory tower
arguments.
But what happens in the university's
happens in society five to 10 years
later.
And so,
and that's exactly what's happening
right now.
So
I think these,
these leads us into the me to a debate
because will you have people in Sweden
right now?
I think the,
me too phenomenon is much larger in
Sweden than in any other country.
I mean,
it's,
it's dominated the media for one month
now.
And,
uh,
every profession has,
has an mi to a sort of article with
thousands of women,
uh,
signing on to it.
So the teachers and the lawyers and the
doctors.
So what one thing is interesting about
this is how the men are handling it
because
um,
there are a lot of men writing that I as
a man,
uh,
have a responsibility for this
happening.
I a man as a male,
I'm responsible and I'm guilty and
actually it was one.
So there are a lot of articles like
that.
And then one of them,
one of the men that was accused of doing
something inappropriate,
it was the former leader for the left
Radical Party.
And if the thing he had done was,
was not so reprehensible,
he had approached a woman and then she
had said no and he had apologized,
but then she didn't accept that.
Then now he's under investigation police
investigation and we have this sort of
witch hunt
is that almost all,
all manifestations of male sexuality are
going to be brought under legal control.
And he actually wrote
the article that said,
yes,
I am responsible because I say I'm
responsible.
I'm better than the majority of men's
reactions to this.
So actually he turned the thing that he
was being under investigation into
because he showed that because he
admitted he showed that he was better.
Yup.
So,
so
it's very our stay,
I mean the whole idea was that you were
supposed to come to terms with your
class guilt and then confess and then,
and then indicate that you could be
brought back into the etiological fold
properly.
The thing is,
it's a lot of muddy thinking.
It's like,
well man should take responsibility for
their aggressive sexuality and they
should incorporate it.
Right.
Because if you repress it,
it just comes out in the most ugly way.
So I mean,
part of the ideas that men,
boys should be socialized like little
girls,
you know?
But that's complete rubbish.
In fact,
even little girls perhaps shouldn't be
socialized like little curls,
but whatever.
I mean that's beside the point that that
aggressive capacity that's associated
with sexuality as well as Freud pointed
out so long ago,
needs to be integrated within the
personality so that it's under control,
right?
And then it's,
it's the hint of darkness and it's the
capacity for malevolence,
but it's,
but it's brought under,
but it's brought under civilized
regulation.
And so then you get to have your cake
and eat it too,
right?
You can be strong and potentially
dangerous and mysterious and all of
those things that,
that are definitely attractive.
That's an attractive features of men,
not only to women,
but also to other men.
So you have to take responsibility for
that.
But that doesn't mean that you should
identify yourself as the member of a
guilty group because of a class based
accusation.
Right.
That's just,
you're not guilty as the member of a
class.
I mean,
that's part of the reason that I've been
pushing so hard against these
postmodern,
neo Marxist ideas because one of their
essential predicates is that you can be
guilty as the member of a class.
And that is,
I don't know if there's a more dangerous
idea then,
then that there might be,
because you know,
there's a very large number of extremely
dangerous ideas,
but that one's,
that one's up near the top.
Yeah.
It's happening to great degree in the
United States to lesser so in Canada,
but every day there's another slew of,
of influential man who are being outed
for their past sexual misbehavior and,
you know,
and that,
and,
and that's,
that's,
uh,
I don't have much to say about that
except that to use that as evidence for
the
group-based guilt of men as such.
Yeah.
Well,
whatever,
I'm going to get a hell of a lot worse
before it gets better,
I'm afraid.